open up the book
oh
and it comes with a baby baby
[Applause]
Meghan Trainor
yep revealing she's pregnant with baby
number two a lot of emotions the singer
made the big announcement on The Today
Show first sharing she's writing a
motherhood advice book dear future mama
after having a baby you all know I just
feel like I could do anything and this
is a big goal of mine because when I was
pregnant I felt very alone it was all
also like covert time so I didn't have
any friends that were pregnant with me
and I just remember being like I don't
want anyone else to feel like that yeah
that's be easy on yourself but when
hodakapi took a peek inside the book
that's when Megan surprised them all I
see your little cutie look open up the
book
oh
[Applause]
my gosh
are you kidding me by the way the tick
tock teaser you put out was like not
much of a tease oh yeah the pop star and
her hubby Daryl Sabara teased the
pregnancy news in this Tick Tock over
the weekend writing telling my family
the secret I've been keeping for the
past few months
[Music]
houses
[Applause]
right I'm like yo two dogs gonna eat
this up like I truly I just have a lot
more friends on Tick Tock and like
that's my home Megan and Daryl are
already parents to one-year-old son
Riley
[Music]
what has surprised you most about
motherhood
oh how much I cry I don't know like
happy tears every night he falls asleep
in my arms and then I look at him and my
husband and I tear up with happy tears
so I'm like this is all I've ever wanted
as far as prepping the little guy to be
a big brother he doesn't understand it
quite yet yeah we try to say baby in
mama's belly and he just points to his
belly now and he's like baby so we're
like okay and whether Megan and Daryl
are expecting a boy or a girl they're
keeping that a secret but we're saving
it for tick tock
oh we're so so happy for y'all oh my God
I love announcing my pregnancies with
you guys
[Applause]
foreign